and I grew up in Louisiana I grew up a
lot of homophobia I grew up with a guy I
hated gay people he was obsessed with
gay guys taking the rainbow that was
like his big beef gay guys took the
rainbow I'm like that might be the
gayest complaint I've ever heard my
entire life
took the rainbow I don't know if they
took it they just made it their flag and
we all know God hates Flags but
her argument would be mentally
each people taking the word special
think that's a better argument that
word's changed a lot over the years
special ed special needs Special
Olympics it's confusing now I go to
restaurants like you want to hear about
the specials I'm like what the [__] you
guys cook
what the hell is going on in that
kitchen huh
whatever it is I'm sure it's slow cooked
but either way I don't know